six months ago I investigated cryptozoo
a scam created by Logan Paul and a team
of criminals oh and a dude named Jeff
which ultimately resulted in millions of
dollars being stolen from fans I was
threatened with a lawsuit for exposing
it but ultimately Logan Paul decided to
thank me instead for his public
undressing and announced a 1.8 million
dollar refund to the victims now I
thought that was a great ending to the
story but I also said this I'll follow
up in the future to make sure that he
actually gives that money away and
that's why we're here today it's been
six months so here's a follow-up Logan
Paul has not paid back his victims he
hasn't talked about it since he first
announced he was going to pay them back
and what's worst of all he doesn't seem
to have a plan in place to refund anyone
how do I know that well because I've
been asking Logan for that plan to
refund people the entire time behind the
scenes in messages like these quote hey
Logan following up on the zoo refunds
when should people expect those it's
been about a month and then a month
later following up again people are
wondering what's going on almost been
two months very frustrating for victims
to get promises and then see nothing and
get zero communication and then later
hey Logan following up for a third time
it's been over five months since you
promised to refund the victims of
kryptozoo over three million dollars I
meant to say 1.8 million dollars there
the price of crypto changed a lot so
what this buyback was gonna be was
constantly changing I just misspoke
there either way my point was this quote
you haven't contacted any of them nor
explained why you haven't done what you
said you do meanwhile you got Public
Credit for promising to do this and all
of this Logan didn't respond to which is
God since he was such a fan of me
reaching out to him personally you know
instead of making things public maybe we
could have talked about this if you had
reached out to me personally not my
manager Jeff who is not me me Steven
well I did reach out to you and I got no
response in fact the only response I got
came on my fourth attempt to reach Logan
but this one came from his criminal
defense lawyers a guy named Jeffrey
Neiman emailed me after my fourth
attempt saying Steven see inserted on
behalf of Logan Paul now to be honest I
had no idea who Logan Paul was until I
researched the lawyer and learned that
he quote regularly defends individuals
and corporations in White Collar
criminal litigations and that's when I
realized oh that logo Paul why didn't
you just say you defended alleged
white-collar criminals would have saved
me a Google search so I opened up the
letter and it read we represent Logan
Paul Mr Paul has informed us of your out
reach about the status of the cryptozoo
BuyBacks Mr Paul remains committed to
this process we are working with Mr Paul
to evaluate the best way to achieve this
goal in the meantime please direct to
our attention any further inquiries to
Mr Paul thank you for your patience and
understanding now that might seem like a
good step in the right direction to you
at least we got a response on behalf of
logel but when I read their response
carefully I realized things were
actually worse than I thought because
two things are absent from this
statement one a timeline for refunds and
two a plan for refunds I mean you have
this abominable statement which says we
are working with Mr Paul to evaluate the
best way to achieve this goal uh
so you're still at the Whiteboard then
guys this is a statement you say when
you have no plan or you're stalling
right you say we're evaluating the best
options I mean that's where Logan was
back in January he was evaluating am I
supposed to believe six months later you
guys haven't figured this out you've
gathered all the boys in the office
brainstorming every single day how do we
refund people and you don't know I mean
listen he had more of a plan Logan did
back in January I'm not even sure what
there is to even still figure out
because way back then January 16th he
said I've committed more than 1.8
million for those who do not want to
wait for cryptozoo to be completed
players will be able to burn their base
eggs and base animals for their mint
price I mean there it is that's the plan
pay a blockchain Dev to code that up and
pay the victims their money that's it
but we see absolutely no sign of that
and it's not for a lack of Logan having
the cash he's done a world tour for
Prime right now bragging about how much
money his drink company is making in
January of this year we we did 45
million in January yeah wow 45 million
is a good month
also January happens to be the same
month
Logan promised those crypto Zoo refunds
so there's no good explanation for why
Logan hasn't refunded his victims yet
because he had a plan back in January he
had the money but there's even less of a
good explanation for why he hasn't
explained himself for the delay to
either me privately or to the victims
publicly who are just waiting around for
months with no word about the status of
their promised Refund Now eventually I
do believe Logan will address this I
think he has to and when he does I think
he'll probably point to a lawsuit that
he's in for the reason he couldn't speak
he had to be silent only he's tried this
before and it didn't make a lot of sense
then either I had to rely on my team
I crumbled internally and the advice was
while actual legal process was going on
because of criminal investigation taking
place at Coffee Zilla highlighted in his
series I had to stay silent and for a
year
I'm hounding Jeff
hounding Jeff how do we make this right
all right let's get this straight Logan
was dying to make crypto Zoo right the
first time but was legally required to
be silent until a YouTuber talked about
it did the judge magically unseal his
lips when my video dropped I'm confused
he's not prevented from explaining
himself and he's certainly not legally
prevented from giving people their money
back even if you want to argue the point
that maybe Logan might look more guilty
if he promises to pay victims well sure
but he already did that though he said
he felt so bad that he was going to
refund 1.8 million dollars to the
affected people who invested but
actually delivering that promise doesn't
add any layer of admission to that guilt
he already said he was responsible at
this point refunding people is just
doing what he said he was gonna do from
the beginning no I think the real reason
Logan hasn't paid if I had to guess is
just because either he does not want to
pay he cannot be bothered to pay on time
or he's just stalling all of which are
unacceptable because let me remind you
of his promise quote I have committed
more than 1.8 million dollars for those
who do not want to wait for cryptozoo to
be completed that is what he said and
the people are tired of waiting
including me after months of trying to
work behind the scenes and ask questions
behind the scenes privately to him I'm
just out of ideas and I'm stuck trying
to speak to Logan in the only language I
believe he understands
self-interest Logan if I could speak to
you for a second okay bring in the
camera
[Music]
this isn't worth your time getting
publicly flogged like this every six
months what are you gonna be doing this
in a year no okay it's not worth your
time it's barely worth my time
just please pay the people back what you
owe give them a real timeline a real
plan and then we can all go back to
pretending you've changed